because we love al veggie might we all
enjoy el veggie much it puts a rose in
every cheek the veggie by jiggle is
there a jingle for wasabi
there's no jingle have you ever had any
Australian snacks before I don't know if
the snacks I've had where Australia or
not so who knows I'm excited yeah I'm
excited to try Japanese snacks I don't
know if I want to try dried squid but
are we gonna taste items good let's do
it yes okay sweet
they're called complete ko and they're
basically like ice cream cones but like
freeze-dried I was going to say it looks
like I said yeah but like it's not but
isn't that so this is an iced Bobo this
is I still love these growing up it's
like a cookie with marshmallow with jam
in the center and then coconut this is
the type of thing that I would eat at
the end of a long day with a cup of hot
tea a nice iceberg where are they called
servers I actually have no idea but they
are delicious okay so it's la yeah
say good oh we actually swapped it okay
now I feel like the iceberg varies they
definitely didn't look like that when I
was a kid we both smaller than before I
do what every snack is like this now
okay let's try it
that's good yeah that's good I like
anything with coconut oh you can really
I can really taste the strawberry jam
that's good I'd buy this yes I'd buy
this
mmm that's good
oh that's yummy this is very Airy yeah
it's like it's very like hollow but it's
like kinda like melts right it's like
not too intense but it's kind of like
icing so he won he won I'll go with this
for now go with this one I guess there's
a clear winner yeah this wins for me I
thought that they weren't gonna be that
good
but I tried it and they better the looks
are deceiving that looks terrifying this
is coffee jelly it's actually pretty
popular in Japan I'll be honest yeah
this is also jelly but it's made out of
seaweed well this is airplane jelly its
port wine flavor yeah this is my
favorite maybe it was like foreshadowing
my love of wine they have a jingle um
it's like I like aeroplanes jelly ever
plain jelly for me top that is going on
their catch is consistency
I'm sorry jelly
I don't like that it's good I love it
poor one some-something's like supposed
to be like wine mmm right or no it's not
you give it to your kids alcohol it I
can't swallow this can you taste the
seaweed no but it's like I didn't like
the consistency okay it's like really
dense for jelly like that's I feel like
that's how jellies meant to me yeah yeah
I can't this is very confusing to me
jelly feels not natural and now I'm
remembering that I never really ate this
because I don't like jelly
it could how could this flavor port-wine
nothing to like the majority of
Australians are alcoholics you can say
like gateway with me out wine yeah I
like this this is good I do like the
flavor of this it's the texture that I'm
just like no it's like what I imagine if
I poked a jellyfish that would happen
I'm gonna do airplane jelly again like
nope right now I mean so airplane jelly
because the wine flavor is actually
that's what it is it's the wine flight
life if you have like orange you would
be like over here yeah I don't know I
like that one more oh yeah yeah I like
that one more yeah I like the taste of
this bed up at the texture of this but
if I had to pick one I would not pick
either of them um you're gonna be trying
Vegemite there it is I like I had a
feeling it was like that yeah have you
ever had this before never had it
I feel like Australians get like great
pleasure in watching paper from other
countries tried Vegemite because it's
pretty disgusting and then this is green
peas it's like precious just like
dehydrated green peas right but it's got
like a wasabi coating on it okay I've
actually had these and it delicious
they're so good I love it
yeah it's Vegemite economy taken clear
um yeah I guess I would call it a
condiment a spread okay I wouldn't put
it on a hot dog
yeah I mean like I'm gonna put it with
sabe on a hunch
y'all make it for you we'll use like but
the trick is to not put too much bad you
might on the toes you just want a thin
layer of it the budget of Vegemite ratio
needs to be like 98 to 298 it's a yeah
like so much about up yeah try this just
take a bite okay oh my like mouth is
like salivating all of a sudden like it
ya know it's it's like you just need way
more butter to Vegemite it's good with
the butter how do you like that
yeah this is also like it's good it's
intense but once the wasabi flavor goes
away it just tastes like a crunchy salty
thing yeah I love them I could eat this
whole packet this one is good because
the wasabi flavor is not so overpowering
yeah I like them but Vegemite for me
wins takes the cake
I'm done with the Masada piece by far I
actually pick the Vegemite I always
wanted to try it you never have and this
is my first experience you would never
and you would never have been you might
like just funny time mm-hmm
it's like yeah suicide I gotta go I
gotta go with the wasabi drink you
mm-hmm
I just like that sensation yeah yeah
they're they're feeling yeah feeling
apart so what did you think about your
first time trying Australian snacks I
liked it I thought like they're all very
good no no the one that really stood out
for me was the Vegemite Japanese ones
with delicious sorry this is what
sobbing pain I definitely go out to a
Japanese grocery store and look in the
snack aisle I am sure that you're gonna
find something that you love I really
did not like to jelly but I've learned
something about myself today is that I
did not like jelly I could live my life
without jelly yes jelly something that
can stay in the jail yeah
[Music]